ladies German 50-cent the musician has
returned to us you're back then yes you
are never gonna see will see a clip of
the video for 9 shots and you single in
a minute
but it goes back to an early cut
terrible experience in your life if you
guys aren't familiar with this story of
what happened it's amazing go well that
pressure right I got you know shot nine
times but it was one time so and I just
didn't see the person coming I would
avoid it yes you know this happened and
and I was trying to write a song
conceptually that would define more of
Who I am so I wrote nine shots and just
picked nine painful moments that I
experienced in my life and used the shot
as a metaphor but the night where were
you shot where look in front of my
grandmother's house but where it
cuz I gave you the doctor's office I got
it look most of them in the legs I get
hit my hand and they hit in the face
so like the fragment portion of it is in
my tongue so it kind of changed when I
speak a little bit like and you're
rapping yeah what is it still in your
tongue
can you see yeah it's great for oral sex
let's make a note of that
I'm a better man now but is another good
lover can you see it yeah let's have a
feel 50 i watch my hands
make so old section did you go in my
mouth hey I better not have a look have
a look see if you can ask him no no Zedd
I'm gonna kiss your tisha a clean one oh
look these ladies easy thank you very
odd for in them look at still look
that's it romantically sealed thank you
very much there they go wow how will you
prepare did someone tell you to come
with this how did that happen what's the
odds of that you'd be sitting in the
front row with this yes who does this
kind of stuff right me happens on this
program honestly we I could feel it
there we go yeah eBay tonight
wait till tomorrow night after the show
they'll be worth a loss
ended up under the table with a very
famous action I can't remember who it
was we were putting like only actors can
we were putting the whole world to write
well I don't know why she what well he
used to get quite aroused when whenever
I got in his back yeah